in this video i'm going to talk to you
about why you never should listen to
your parents at any age
hi my name's alex ramose i own a
portfolio of companies that has 85
million
a year in revenue and i have absolutely
nothing to sell you i make this channel
because a lot of people are broken i
don't want you to be one of them
and so one of the things that happens
and this is at any age like i know guys
who are making millions of millions of
dollars a year and still
uh you know are insecure about what
their parents tell them about xyz
and so the reason i think this is
interesting is that most people
unless your parents are exorbitantly
wealthy and have achieved everything
that you wish to achieve i don't think
you should listen to your parents
and so one of my first rules of life is
never listen to someone who's poorer
than you or poor than you want to be
all right so that's two different you
know caveats there because you might be
younger and it's like okay well yeah my
parents have more money than me but like
are they poorer than you want to be
if so then only listen to people who are
wealthier than you want to be right and
the thing is is that
they always will and other people too
right will always
side on the side of being less less
risky right and here's why
because when you naysay right it's like
kind of like when you're um
if someone's like oh i don't like your
your girlfriend and and the thing is is
that
if you date in general right and dating
can apply
like the concept of dating and apply to
business concepts it doesn't really
matter but
if you date then fundamentally every
single person that you date except for
the one that you marry
is going to be somebody who you're not
going to be with and if someone says i
don't think this person's good i don't
think this person's good then they will
be right literally 99 of the time except
for the one time that matters
right kind of interesting and so the
thing is
is most businesses fail ninety-five
percent of businesses fail within five
years
right and so most times they are correct
and so it's very easy for them to
self-reinforce that they are so smart
right and they're always right and they
could tell you i told you so
right but the reality is that they are
wrong in the one percent of times that
it matters
right in your life and so when i think
about this
what's interesting is that like the only
way that is guaranteed to knock you to
success is to never take the risk to
begin with right that's the guaranteed
way of not achieving it
and i remember when i was quitting my
job that was the biggest conclusion that
i came to was that
i was not happy at my current earning
level and that the only job because
there was one position one job that made
enough money that i wanted which was
being an investment banker so the best
investment bankers can make 10 20
million
a year but i knew what it was required
to get there in the amount of effort
time and sacrifice and i was like the
only people who will pay me that amount
of money
um will be making so much more money off
of me
and literally draining my life that i
don't think it's because like usually if
you become an investment banker that's
successful you pretty much donate 20
years of your life
in order to do that um and you're you're
really never going to see your family
and all that kind of stuff and for me
that was not a
trade-off i wanted to make and so i
figured there was no job that was going
to pay me what i wanted to make
and afford me the lifestyle that i
wanted and so
the path that i was on was guaranteed
to not get me to where i wanted to go
and so even though it was
micro risky it was macro
the only way i could do it right and so
that's one of those like one of those
things actually like from garyvee that
he says microspeed macro patience right
money loves speed wealth less time and
so if we're trying to build wealth we're
trying to build an
asset right then we need to have time
one of my other favorite sayings that
i'll share with you is um
uh you get paid for what you do you get
returns while you own
right and so anyways back to the back to
the reason why you shouldn't listen to
um
other people is that they don't have an
accurate understanding of risk right
and the biggest risk is not doing
anything at all the biggest risk is
never dating
not that you're with this person right
and so warren buffett said and i like
this he said
most people only need to make four or
five really good decisions in their life
so think about that for a second because
i think about like that one really shook
me because i think about all the
decisions that i make every single day
right and all the decisions that i've
made in my life
and there's really not that many of them
that have been the biggest levers but
the few that have been
have been massive and enormous levers in
my life and most people don't take
enough time to think about those
decisions that are the massive force in
the road
am i going to keep going in this
position do i want to live in the city
am i going to marry this girl who am i
going to go to
uh who am i going to get into business
with uh what are we going to do right
what are we actually going to do
in this business and so people don't
give put enough thought into that stuff
and spend all their time thinking about
what next show they're going to watch on
netflix right rather than thinking like
i'm going to take some time with this
decision
because one of my other sayings is
mistakes love a rushed decision
right so microspeed macro patience if
you're looking at long
playing long then you have to understand
or at least this is my you know
my two cents on it is that most people
will oppose you at all times and that is
because it is safer for them to do so
because they will be right most of the
times but on the one percent of times
that they are wrong it's that one
percent decision
saying that you're going to buy c's
candies for 25 million dollars and ends
up generating a billion dollars right
in revenue it's that one decision that
they're going to miss out on and that's
the one decision that matters
and so they are 99 of the time right but
they're 100
wrong right and so that's the only
message that i wanted to
really drive home is that if you have
parents who make less money
than you want to make if you have
friends who make less money than you
want to make i had so many people who
told me that everything i was doing was
stupid i was giving up a really good
consulting job to open a gym
right i took all my savings and sunk
into a business and you know what
that business wasn't the one that set me
free it was four four or five businesses
from there
but i learned the skills that one by one
i was able to assemble
and assemble on a belief standpoint of
the world with the character traits to
reinforce them to eventually
yield the success that some people think
is you know cool so anyways
um i made this video because i've had um
a lot of younger people who reached out
to me recently
about this particular issue and it's
just understanding macro risk versus
micro risk
micro risk yes you will fail but failure
is part of the game
right but the macro risk is that you'll
never actually succeed and that's the
real game
right and so you have to understand that
you have to date in order to find the
girl you're going to marry you have to
go on a lot of bad dates you have to
have a lot of small businesses that
don't work
right you don't have to but it's common
and i don't know any entrepreneur who
hasn't had a lot of businesses
uh who eventually yielded success right
or even a lot of businesses within their
main business they pivoted a lot of
times until they figured out what they
were good at what the market needed i
hope that makes sense to you i hope you
found value this
uh i'm rooting for you i'm your biggest
fan keeping awesome keep taking risks
microspeed macro patience and um you get
paid for what you do
you get returns on what you own and what
we're trying to build here is an asset
that can pay us over time because if we
cannot learn how to build that asset we
will work until the day we die
so i'm keeping awesome muscle love and
i'll catch you guys in the next video
hit subscribe if you like it
and if you don't don't subscribe uh
i'll get you soon alright bye